欢迎你学习 白泽国际站运营实战系统课 同学们 上一节课 我们主要讲了关于新店铺运营的三个阶段 那么这一节课 我们来讲解一下新店铺运营的一些具体的实战方法步骤 那么如果你不清晰怎么做的话 那么我们先跟着做 第一个就是我们做新店铺的时候一定要目标明确 一定要把人群分析清楚 你的目标跟方向就清晰了 那么你所做的事情就更加有积累性
第一个就是店铺定位 那么这个方法我们前面已经讲了 你要去从赛道 产品线 国家人群 产品知识 这些都必须去掌握和分析清楚 明确起来 那么如果你对这个店铺定位还不是很清楚 那么可以回顾我们之前所学的内容
第二个板块就是选热品 那么这个关于选品 我们前面也讲了 如何去选品 如何去切入我们的店铺主营产品 那么前面都可以回顾一下 怎么样去学 第一个就是参考市场款式 第二个就是同行的优秀产品 第三就是精挑一到三个品类进行切入 第四流量大且稳定的优先 你按照这种实度去做 那么第三个步骤就是组合报款标题
这个组合标题 我们前面也讲了 你只需要参考这个思路 具体的每一个步骤 用上每一个步骤的方法就可以了
比如说 第一个单品类 你要组20个标题 全面覆盖你的这个品类的所有的关键词 三个月内要发200到500个产品 建议就是越快越好 特别是在第一周内
你要尽可能发多产品 你的店铺所覆盖的池多了 那么能够快速的获得流量 同时呢也有利于你后期快速的推广
不要浪费这些宝贵的三个月的扶持期 第四个步骤就是你把产品发了 那么你要马上开始推广了
不要等待 第一周内马上开启推广 用新品加速计划去推广 同时同一个品类放一个计划
比如说你A B 3个品类或者是3类产品
那么你不要混合计划去把这A B C都放在同一个计划推广
你要分计划 比如A A品类放在A计划推广 B品类放在B计划推广
C品类放在C计划推广 按照这样分品类去推广
你前面不是已经按照店铺定位已经把这些什么国家人群是吧
把国家人群已经明确了 那么你开始在推广的时候
就要锁定你目标的国家跟人群 你的直通车开始的时候不是L0等级吗 L0等级的话 我们是要重点先溢价国家 也就是这些国家我要高溢价 高于人群溢价 人群溢价
所以你在推广的时候一定要先高溢价国家 人群稍微低点溢价 因为你现在是L0 当你到L3的时候就反过来
人群高一价 国家低一价 甚至国家只一价101 按照这个思路 出价的话 你前期不要出过低的价格 比如说你们的底价是3元 如果你也出3元的话 一个容易导致你没有流量 第二就会导致你的整个引流进来的人群的质量会比较低 所以说前期可以采用高一点出价 这样有利于你提升整个店铺的人群的质量
第五步就是去精挑产品 也就是在我们推广的这个阶段中 我们要把好的产品留下来 持续的优化跟推广 已经给我们带来询盘的产品 我们要去看一下这些询盘的质量怎么样 一定要去判断一下 如果询盘的质量非常差 一定要去及时调整
不要等待 因为等它积累的越多 那么你店铺所积累的这些人群标签就越多
那么你后期系统给你推荐的这类低质量的循环就会越多
后期你要想改善这种情况就是非常难的
所以一定要重视这个阶段 挑产品 把好的留下
留下好的一定要去判断它的质量怎么样 就是循环质量怎么样
第六个步骤的话就针对这些好的产品 以及高转化的产品
比如说可能这些产品已经成为了实力品或者爆品 是吧
那么如果是它成为这个阶段的时候
那么我们一定要重点要用信保去扶持 只有用信保去扶持了 那么它的权重提升了 那么它获得自然流量
以及推荐的流量就多了 这两个板块的流量多了之后 那么它许满了量就会提升 许满量提升之后我们再确保一下质量
整体上来说 它就能够给你带来更多的一个订单 订单这个维度
那么这个就是关于我们整个新店铺的一个整体的运营流程
如果我们跑完了这个流程之后 这是第一次开始的时候
那么第二次也是一样按照这个流程 循环流程 不断的循环 不断的循环
那么你后期积累的这些优质的产品就越来越多
那么你这个店铺就有可能快速做起来了
所以说前期我们不要铺开的面太广
而是要从部分品类先切入 跑完整个流程 然后接着继续复制 按照这样有效的方法持续的复制
那么你这个店铺剩下的产品都是好产品 这就是关于我们新店铺的一个运营的一个具体的实操方法和具体的一个步骤
那么如果你对整个新店铺或者是刚接手一些新店不知道怎么去做 那么你就可以参考这个流程去做
这里面每一个具体的操作我们在前面都有讲过 你只需要知道这个方向 知道这个思路 再去学习对应的方法 那么整个店铺他一定会朝着一个更加好的方向去发展 那么这节课我们就先讲到这里 下节课我们再见